en plein spring break les vacances
étudiantes de printemps jusqu'à ce
vendredi les plages de floride était
noir d'étudiants et de touristes
malgré les consignes de distanciation
sociale mardi le gouverneur de floride
avait annoncé la fermeture pour 30 jours
des bars boîtes de nuit et salles de
sport et interdit tout rassemblement de
plus de 10 personnes
mais devant le peu de respect des
consignes il a durci les règles en
fermant les plages nous comprenons les
mesures qu'ils prennent et parce que la
situation est très grave
mais en tant que touristes ici vous
voulez visiter vous voulez apprendre et
on est à miami mais on ne fait rien on
n'apprend rien on ne peut même pas
acheter du tout la seule chose qu'on
veut faire c'est rentré wayne mais il
n'y a pas de vols pour le moment donald
trump exclu de confiner l'ensemble du
pays mais quelques états l'illinois le
new jersey le connecticut
la californie et l'état de new york ont
choisi des mesures plus restrictives que
celles annoncées au niveau fédéral j'ai
regardé ce qui se passait en californie
avec le gouverneur gavin newsom et ce
matin avec le gouverneur andrew cuomo
avait de nouveau et je les applaudis
ils prennent des mesures très fort et
audacieux
le président américain s'est dit une
nouvelle occasion de renforcer le
contrôle aux frontières pour lui les
migrations global de masse risquerait
d'épuiser les ressources nécessaires
pour soigner les américains lors d'une
pandémie mondiale
ils menacent de créer les conditions
parfaites pour que nous allions à la
frontière soit contaminé les migrants
aussi et le public en général si on ne
contrôle pas ça ça pourrait paralyser
notre système d'immigration surchargé
notre système de santé est portée
sévèrement atteinte à notre sécurité
nationale
on ne va pas laisser cela se produire
washington a annoncé la fermeture des
frontières avec le mexique et avec le
canada pour tous les voyages non
essentiels